so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up guys my name is Thomas
dobizola whatever you want to call me
this is the dope's usual podcast thank
you guys for being here thank you for if
you're driving please drive safe with
that being said this is my co-host Marty
O'Neill self products what up guys all
right so I just want to say that driving
thing because I got a couple more DMS of
people crashing what all the time every
every month almost so you all right my
car listen to your show but yo be safe
one guy said I was laughing hella hard
and rear ending someone that went
I'm glad you're okay but that kind of is
awesome it's kind of almost acceptable
it's almost yeah it's almost like all
right cool but guys here we go we're
back for another episode and you guys
asked every eight seconds all right
every eight seconds for people to come
back on and this is highly number one or
two besides Goblin thank you for coming
back this is the aricon episode what's
up again again guys we're back chilling
let's do it man this is like number two
or three or number three or four oh yeah
something like that something like that
I don't know dude these have all like
this is conversation so it's not brand
new anymore so it's yeah lose count how
long yeah how long has it been since you
started started this we started in
February February 21 yeah
um
oh five episodes out of 100 and I'm
still still only half of a pull-up and I
said by episode 100 I'll get a full one
I'm like I get here and then I max out
so maybe in five weeks we'll see because
I said okay man good news about that bet
is there was no Stakes yeah that's true
I didn't lose anything
um dude since you've been here last
you've been doing a lot decent like a
lot less yeah likewise yeah we've been
out out and about not even that a lot in
terms of I'm just gonna skip ahead here
real quick
since we've talked to you last you have
a up and running full weekly maybe
bi-weekly podcast yeah oh yeah bi-weekly
or weekly It's weekly I feel like you
guys post so much I feel like it's more
than that yeah yeah there's um like
other content that we Post in there as
well maybe that's kind of have like
other series and stuff but yeah the
podcast is every week every Friday and
for everyone out there what is this
called it's called Pine Park after dark
I like the name and it's with the Tim
secret search right yeah 100 and then
josefo is the producer great ass guy
that guy's awesome yeah I love the
camera work man on that episode
we tried to do that first episode we had
somebody walking around yeah with a
handheld and it just didn't it was
awesome it just didn't work out
ultimately but I love the camera I love
the movement it's just it's dope yeah um
how did that come about I know you
because you started like concast yeah
yeah I remember that thing oh man I was
trying to do myself and it's hard to do
yourself bro it's [ __ ] yeah that's
like the main thing that I realized over
the past like few years I was I thought
I was like this [ __ ] Super Genius and
[ __ ] I was like I can steal all this
[ __ ] or something like I'm the next
[ __ ] like Elon Musk and [ __ ] and I
was like damn even like these like super
Geniuses or whatever like they have an
insane amount of helping a lot of teams
and editors and like this and this and
that and I'm like [ __ ] I've been doing
it wrong [ __ ] yeah I need some help and
[ __ ] so um yeah when um they came to me
for Pine Park which was originally
supposed to be like it was like content
based and they kind of mentioned like a
podcast and everything about it and then
now it's like kind of this like content
Powerhouse almost kind of thing that
we're kind of trying to build together
and it's going to be a good time I'm
excited for it for sure oh dude [ __ ]
yeah it collabs with the Gaming
Community yes like YouTubers the
podcasters yeah and you're a gamer too
yeah so it's the worst yeah 100 are you
into like Call of Duty and all that [ __ ]
too yeah for sure that's what I uh
started that's what I wanted to be a
YouTuber for originally back in high
school it makes even more sense yeah
it's like a full circle kind of moment
yeah I was watching eggs in high school
yeah yeah like years and years and I was
like damn I'm trying to be a part of
optic oh like that's how like oh [ __ ]
I'm trying to be like crack and try to
be a part of this team and everything
and then I just excited like falling off
the game and I was like man I'm just not
really a fan of it anymore the Call of
Duty started being whack you know I'm
sure you know so I was like that's when
I just started uploading the weed
content and everything
um but it's kind of crazy to have it all
kind of go back around and it's like I
didn't know they used to watch in high
school that makes it so much it's like
you know I'm a Kobe Bryant fan and now I
just played against it yeah yeah that's
pretty awesome on your terms with yeah
with you get started a full-on brand
you're part Park yeah yeah it's pretty
[ __ ] crazy yeah it's pretty sweet
it's been cool watching you guys build
it up since you've been on last and like
yeah coming and collaborating yeah for
sure we're building out like the content
part we're also building out the weed we
just launched in Oklahoma a couple weeks
ago which was [ __ ] crazy Oklahoma
smokes which I didn't know they smoked
[ __ ] fat it's a medical erect State
it's medicinal and they're voting in
March so Oklahoma and make sure to vote
and your vote matters because I heard
that the medicinal account only won by
1100 votes so it's going to be tough
it's going to be tough
you know yeah that's what I'm saying get
out there hit the polls make sure weed
becomes legal in Oklahoma so you guys
wouldn't have dropped it like medical
leave yeah yeah we had like a big it was
a pretty sweet dispensary there's just
like awesome laws in Oklahoma but it was
like a [ __ ] fat dispensary and it was
uh the biggest main difference between
here and there not the biggest one but
one of the bigger ones especially for
meet and greets is that you can smoke
weed anywhere you can smoke a cigarette
in Oklahoma
yeah and you can smoke outside of the
dispensaries too that's not illegal like
it is yeah yeah they have like security
guards
you can't even come back that's what I'm
saying so it was just a really good like
environment it was a free-for-all in
Oklahoma damn near that's whatever
that's what I always heard I was like
Oklahoma was like the Wild Wild West
yeah yeah in what way but then you go
there and you're like [ __ ] the fact you
can smoke weed were you where you smoke
cigs is great because that's New York
[ __ ] yeah
for Oklahoma that means you can smoke
right in your meet and greet line
because we did it in Indiana one and I'm
like oh I would still feel paranoid in a
state that just went like damn I'm just
gonna have to explain to this guy the
laws and [ __ ] yeah for sure but it turns
out there was um there was like a police
training academy like down the street so
there was like cars driving back and
forth they didn't [ __ ] with it once so
you're really comfortable yeah they're
just like driving back and forth I guess
making sure she wasn't going crazy but
they never just nice yeah so the
internet was good it was great it was
awesome saw the video or the pictures
like the snaps of it or something yeah
especially because it was Oklahoma but
there's like more people there than like
the LA one like the crazy [ __ ] right
yeah you get like the I'm sure it was
for you it's like Illinois yeah much
bigger than the LA one were you in the
city or kind of in the middle of nowhere
uh it was like okay see like kind of it
was like 10 minutes from the airport
like okay she's not that big so it's
like a 20 minute drive everywhere kind
of thing so people were able to make it
out a lot of people were from Tulsa it
was almost like 40 of the people were
from Tulsa which is like an hour hour
and a half away which is awesome so okay
we're gonna come back and do something
there that's the biggest private City
out there right I think okay UKC is the
capital I think I don't know I could be
wrong about that I could be wrong
somebody's in the comments yeah they are
wrong yeah but you're currently in
school
sorry
geography's not my [ __ ] important
thing of the day that's what I'm saying
how many minutes are we can we get high
yet yeah yeah you look recovered you're
back I see it yeah so before if
anybody's wondering like why are you
looking crying I touch my eyes with weed
right before he got here I had to go get
eye drops that's how bad it got my they
were blood red so I'm sure I'm gonna
gain back my eyes
um Bubble Gum lemon
I like the lemon one okay but the
bubblegum one is delicious now is it
really difficult opening up a store like
somewhere out of the state versus the uh
sometimes it's easier so when Oklahoma
first opened up I heard it was like oh
These are nice it was like
less than 5 000 to get a license for
something
five bands and that was and there's only
like a certain amount yeah yeah there's
only a certain amount but it was um for
the first like few months it was almost
a free-for-all as long as you had the
money you could get the cultivation
license you get the storefront license
you can get everything for under like
20K you're like oh [ __ ] it was [ __ ]
crazy so now there's a there's more
dispensaries in Oklahoma than there is
California
weeds like that wait wait is that a fact
it's a fact there's more in the whole
state in the whole state than in
California yeah and they're not even
recreational no it's [ __ ] insane
there's like you'll show up to a block
and it'll be like gas stations there'll
be like they're just like gas stations
are it'll be three dispensaries on the
Block what for like blocks and blocks
and blocks it's [ __ ] crazy yeah why
not like go get the money artwork what
the [ __ ] are we doing that's how it
should be it's crazy yeah and especially
because it's wreck when it becomes
recreational it's like an hour and a
half from Dallas and Dallas in Texas
wow that's your area right yeah Texas
Texas yeah so you know like why do you
think so many people are showing up
I don't know honestly
um I just didn't I just they just smoke
like people from every single estate
just smoke like that and I get that but
you know what I mean like you figure La
it's the popular spot yeah because you
you and I both like I didn't think that
many people yeah we were both in the
midwest basically yeah like that doesn't
make sense I mean it's awesome it's
awesome but it's like
YouTube analytics are not telling me
about Oklahoma that's because they're
not saying yo Midwest go there that's
what I'm saying but I'd say like maybe I
guess we're big enough that there's like
enough people in every state that it'll
be like cool you know I'm sure you
realize that like doing the tour like
that was [ __ ] cool yeah but expect it
um expect Illinois to be so pop or in
the enemy so popping yeah like you're
like Oklahoma has more people showed up
in L.A that's what I said too like what
the what's going on if that's awesome
you guys went out and didn't meet and
greet so people were probably like meet
you and hex billion yeah if you're fans
of both holy [ __ ] I feel like also
though it's like places like that they
don't have much going on like L.A
there's a meet and greet every [ __ ]
day with like a dinner all the time and
like there's not probably much going on
out there except for like local Hometown
people that probably come back or like
shows and stuff like that you know but I
can't think of nobody I'm not that
exciting yeah yeah
I'm not talking [ __ ] Oklahoma I can't
think of like you know my favorite bands
from Oklahoma I can't think of it yeah
yeah drawing them like no idea
all right well yeah we'll go from there
okay all right so it's successful you
guys are out officially selling legally
in Oklahoma selling illegal weed in
Oklahoma is it the one that was your
strain too the cons
Rosen or something oh no that was uh the
stuff that was no stuff we launched here
yet
um we're doing pens there though which
is going to be exciting
losers yeah yeah I know you know about
that the pens are the move huh it's just
the easiest thing everyone on Earth yeah
that's not bougie [ __ ] we'll smoke a pen
it's
people like no no joint let me hit that
pen and those people that are by the
same strain the same thing every week
re-up make sure they have it those are
the people you want like in your brand
man yeah for surely but yeah [ __ ] yeah
we're gonna launch pens and uh we're
launching a couple more States next year
it's looking like it's gonna be [ __ ]
exciting oh it's getting pretty exciting
yeah are you curating everything still
like are you helping like yeah yeah for
sure yeah yeah these are the interesting
thing is these are the genetics that we
brought from so one of the cuts is uh
one that was grown in like Oklahoma and
one is one that we brought from
California just to see like if people
would care people don't give a [ __ ] with
the genetic side where the weed is grown
it was like this is like the California
exclusive like no one else in the state
has this and the other stuff sold better
than just like it just like it's on the
looks pretty much you know what I mean
the other stuff looked a little better
so that's all it was 90 of the people
readjust there's a reason
cheap water sells faster some people
just want to drink water yeah is it like
hot and sunny there or does it snow and
[ __ ] like I have no concept uh dude so
that's what I thought it was a it was a
crazy thing so it's very um
[ __ ] [ __ ] I think that's the bubble gum
it's the bubble gum no no worries it's
tasting good though
I just hit this one's this lemon
I'm sorry I think I just mixed them up
I'm not my bad I think it's one of those
places where like the winters are very
wintry and then like the summer is very
[ __ ] hot as well and then you get
that weird in between where the days are
both because that's kind of where we
went for like the afternoon was like a
little hot and then the mornings are
like 40 degrees so it's kind of that
like in between but it does snow there I
didn't know
um it snows really heavily like later in
the year but it snowed the day before we
landed and that was apparently like I
asked people at the meet and greet
they're like no that's never happened
like before like it's so early for it to
snow so it's weird global warming and
[ __ ] I guess or whatever yeah Al Gore
yeah wherever you're from
so many fans have been sending me like
uh images at Bill Stadium how the snow's
like taller than all the players and
[ __ ] that's scary yeah no people are
it's it's [ __ ] up getting trapped in
the snow Insurance pleasure thank you
what about next topic
have you ever been to MJ bizcon before
oh yeah yeah what was your take on this
experience for everyone out there we
just went to MJ bizcon he was out there
I was out there in Vegas thankfully
thankfully I wasn't out there for MJ
like and specifically MJ bizcon it was
my girl's birthday so it just kind of
like oh it just lined up I was out there
and everyone was there too no I didn't
realize yeah yeah but I only I only went
once and I was like oh I needed to see a
couple years ago but uh I think I saw
this tweet yeah yeah I saw this tweet
from uh what's I think Ted from Alien
labs and uh the whole tweet was no I
didn't go to MJ bizkid I don't do
cocaine I liked I think yeah yeah and I
was like that pretty much explains it
100 that's like what it is so you didn't
go
I uh I had a booth
um they put me
in the very very very very very [ __ ]
far back by the exit on the second floor
next to Dunkin Donuts wow so first off I
don't think they wanted us there
second
[ __ ] MJ bizcon I kind of had it out
online with these little bastards right
after I talked really just I talked some
[ __ ] I didn't talk [ __ ] I let him know
how I felt right
constructive criticism
I bought a booth I had to pay for every
ticket I got still for everyone in my
company damn for our [ __ ] ticket
every one of them per person per person
[ __ ] oh my God God damn second
I'm in line Hash House his brother me
backpack's full of [ __ ] weed and hash
you can't bring that in because it's a
weed event now I cannot bring weed in
in a legal State at a weed event can't
bring weed in ready and the guy goes
you know you want to throw me some [ __ ]
I'll let you go in that's what he said
so my friend had to bribe with some
pants we all walked in yeah
go in the wackest event I've ever been
the weakest [ __ ] ever you can't smoke 92
percent of the people went like this is
a joint correct is what it's called a
joint that's how I felt man people were
nice it's ridiculous yeah they're
they're nice people yeah
but two of the dudes came up like I'm
ready to get [ __ ] I don't even smoke
no more but I used to smoke in high
school man I smoked a couple blunts you
know and then he's like yeah I got the
company card like where's the strip club
what are we doing
um that was the whole event the whole
event was a frat party did this used to
be a cool event no but at least you
could smoke weed at the one in San
Francisco yeah so uh oh then I was
outside smoking a joint in the back all
these people are smoking cigarettes I'm
like oh we're good the lady started
yelling at every [ __ ] smoking
weed and started screaming I'm gonna
take all your passes if you keep smoking
weed here wow
while she smoke a cig I don't understand
thank God I didn't go yeah I don't
understand this and the whole time like
you know what
don't get too mad and then I'm walking
around and I just see bars
people who whines people drinking um
and I just couldn't [ __ ] take it I
just lost my [ __ ] even go back the third
day I was I wasn't planning on it but I
was just like so upset man yeah I'm glad
you didn't go I will never step foot
again ever unless you want to pay me
like a hundred [ __ ] bands to come
speak and then at the end and go [ __ ]
empty biscon yeah yeah I [ __ ] hate
that place sorry I had to get that off
my chest I thought you went that's why
we put in the notes and [ __ ] [ __ ] that
place the most like Chad Brad conference
ever [ __ ] been to super lame
80 of the booths are just lights
they're like and they were uh tomato
plants there was tomato plants
everywhere yeah there was no weed was
there a lot of fans coming through in
China I met like [ __ ] 12 [ __ ] fans
but they were they can't get in shoes
it's not open to the public yeah
everybody was wearing a tire Blazer oh
is it for like wholesalers or something
no it was for corporate [ __ ]
douchebags I want to go I want to invest
my money into this this makes money
right people smoke this yeah basically
the whole [ __ ] event every one of
those people would call me a drug addict
a year ago but now they're here in the
Cannabis industry and it really bugs
gotcha yeah it's like the culture of
ultra Central Academy oh okay it was the
worst thing I've ever seen or been to
damn so you kind of knew it going in but
you didn't realize it was going to be I
didn't know you couldn't bring weed in
the last one I smoked the [ __ ] smoked
it out what are you talking about you
can't smoke [ __ ] you
[ __ ] ridiculous crazy stuff it was
dumb it was dumb I thought you went
Vegas
you're in Vegas yeah um I saw because I
talked to I talked to Nick nice and he's
like yo if you see Eric let him know
he's like he just put 100 on black and
then I saw the Tweet so what happened
for everyone else that follows you on
Twitter
so I'm just chilling at the slots I'm
not I'm not really a slots fan of my
girl like slime she's like super lucky
too I feel like all girls are lucky
that's the last for some reason I don't
know maybe it's like a like it's a
facial recognition there's probably
something going on wait do you have an
asteroid I'm crazy huh yeah I got what's
over here okay I was like dude you don't
have any big boys yeah let me get those
actions yeah but I'm just sitting there
at the slots and then I get a phone call
from Goblin first I get a text and he's
like bro put 100 on blah blah you know
you don't read the whole thing it says
put 100 I'm like [ __ ] Goblin keep
gambling a little bit then he Rings me
and I'm like this guy's like really
trying all right I'm like what's good
man and he said yo 100 black 11 I'll
sell you and you will split it and I was
like [ __ ]
all right like why wouldn't I you know
what I mean I'm down as [ __ ] so he sends
it over and he's like let me know when
you're gonna do it like five minutes
later get the cash hit the table I
FaceTime him and then the guy uh we sit
down you know you can't have the phone
at the table or whatever he's an [ __ ]
about it so I'm like I put over
um try to you know have my friend hold
it or whatever
full table it's the only table open it's
loaded it was [ __ ] Super PAC Vegas
super packed so I just find one see
black 11 and I try not to look at the
numbers before because I know if I see
black 11 like on there I'm like no no
I'd even like psych myself out halfway
playing I've realized those are the
numbers that I've hit already yeah I
wasn't paying attention man I knew I was
gonna like just suck myself up so I'm
not looking I was just like dead
straight zoomed on the 11. just put 100
down
and then it was like the craziest triple
bounce of like my life he spins it it's
like and it goes like once twice and
then shoots back to 11 and just lands on
it and we're like we all just look at
each other that all the tables just
shocked the guy's shocked and then
there's like two of the main like
manager ladies and they're like yeah
they're like cheering I'm like [ __ ] yeah
like those are the [ __ ] real ones
right there so um yeah just [ __ ] hit
36-1 odds put 100 bucks down and then
first time I ever saw like a thousand
chip they elected me you had the [ __ ]
yellow then she gave me three of them
oh [ __ ] but the whole time I didn't
realize that like you know on FaceTime
the camera was off so we were still
FaceTiming but the camera was [ __ ]
off so Goblin just hears us screaming
the whole time
he's like he's like what happened he's
like what happened and then I'm just
like the only thing I do I don't say
anything and I just turn the camera
around and show them the chips and he's
like what the [ __ ] and he like puts his
hand on this [ __ ] and he's like bro he's
like you're trolling he thought he was
trolling for sure but uh we got that
[ __ ] it was nuts it was [ __ ] nuts I
couldn't even believe it the only time
I've ever hit on a number in Vegas
really yeah I've never gambled before
this week whatever oh I didn't play
Blackjack I was 18 my 18th birthday that
was it yeah I never played roulette
never played nothing I walked up and I
hit my first [ __ ] number damn
no I put two down because I didn't know
how I know how it works yeah yeah
and like I said I I thought you just get
your two chips back you double up and
the [ __ ] lady was like here oh shut
the [ __ ] up I got hooked like I told you
before those are so dope it's like a
it's like a rush when you see the
mountains I just didn't realize like
wait so you're telling me if I put five
dollars on a number I went 180 what if I
do the whole board I did the math again
okay
um no all right I'm just gonna pick
these numbers up with Hash House yeah
and we just kept going he could not win
oh that's the worst when you're just I
couldn't see how many 500 cash-ins the
guy did back back
and then I hit my first number Juiced
then I had three numbers in a row oh
Juiced I mean I'm looking at [ __ ] like
yo does I think it was like it's not a
lot of money it's more of like no way
got you yeah I won thanks Bobby I wasn't
friends with every [ __ ] I tipped
everybody every hand I'm like this good
luck oh yeah and I kept hitting and then
they started the dealers were betting
with me like I think you're gonna hit
they're putting five dollars on what I
was betting and then three times
in a row guys I picked a number and it
hit and bounced out
um three times I'm gonna won two bands
three times in a row oh it hurt me so
severely Rosie's got good luck oh she
was hitting she just couldn't lose
damn no way you just couldn't [ __ ]
lose I just kept everything because we
split next to each other I'm like yo
we're monies together yeah don't bet on
the ones I've been on all right cool we
had a better chance and we just I would
lose every everything and she just kept
going the first time I was like I got
the luck and no it went away it went
away
uh Cosmo in the wind nice because I've
never been to the win actually the win
was nice dude there's a high roller
Booth slots so John his brother do the
slots yeah I I wasn't paying attention I
was like oh I'm gonna walk with John
Rose you keep playing I [ __ ] lost
yeah and I was like let's take a break
and I went in there and some big [ __ ]
giant giant fat Mexican dude hit 35
bands on the little hole and he looked
like cool
that was his reaction sick and I heard
him talking to his friends like I'm
still down 120 but like this helps
he had are she looking like Thursday you
know it was a [ __ ] Wednesday it was a
Wednesday night Thursday morning and he
goes we're still down 120 but this helps
and I remember hearing it like ew ew you
ever seen the movie 300 yeah remember
the gold dude with all the chains yeah
so that's what he looks Xerxes he's got
all the chains on he had like six chains
on oh layered layered that but they were
shined like he was a God damn that's a
big fat dude huge dude and and I heard
him saying oh that's disgusting I left
the room go back I lose more money come
back and some guy hit 170. oh on the
slots
170. the guy that 135 was one CH you
know he's like nine Windows yeah eight
one nine it would have been 1.3 and he
was like you could see him like
35. dude some people are so rich if they
don't give a [ __ ] it scares me
yeah that shit's crazy I remember I was
at a roulette table one time and this
lady pulled up and you could tell she
was just you know how you can see those
you could see it on yeah you got the
crazy person like crazy mink code or
whatever and she wrote a check to the
dealer
like hands your face down to the lady
and I was like what they give her back a
[ __ ] mountain of like I think it was
100 chips it was like yeah it was nutty
as [ __ ] and it was like yeah
wow but could you imagine how fun life
is to be like a Saudi Prince billionaire
like yo let's go to Vegas I'm gonna
spend three million you guys gonna have
such a fun time insanely fun time how do
you even spend that much money all right
you can't you can't yeah you gotta buy a
car have it shipped back
find five girls to give them to to hang
out with like you're a billionaire that
never worked
yeah but one of those ladies did roll up
uh it was her birthday she was she was
like
the plastic surgery lady but she was
very cool dude I saw her win like 30
bands on her hand she just kept she had
Stacks like this of black chips on her
numbers oh my God she just didn't give a
[ __ ] she was winning and they were like
I lost all my money
and then I came back through and she had
like
and I talked to the next morning she's
like I lost it all it's like every
[ __ ] dollar Jesus Christ so I would
have been a 10 this morning last time I
saw I was one she said she left at 10.
oh but it's her birthday she's like it's
sexy and you just never know like you're
like oh my God
oh dude it's so fun I didn't realize how
fun gambling is yeah crazy like it's
actually [ __ ] crazy it's like yeah it
is fun it's so fun that you almost don't
even mind losing the money sometimes I
was fluctuating within the same thousand
dollars three days of fun
come on yeah and then I went back to MJ
but it's going on
oh man okay sorry on to the next thing
about the tables though is that same
thing as like MJ business you can smoke
cigs at the table I hate it so there's a
fool right next week with a cigarette
the whole time the whole time every time
my homie
Bob Bob he smokes weed at the table no
[ __ ] he just [ __ ] they don't give a
[ __ ] they're not gonna tell him not to
don't tell him I've seen him snaps and
he's smoking joints at the table like no
one gives a [ __ ] that's a crew
um but yeah I didn't win but it was
[ __ ] fun man it's fun so you you
didn't win either your girl one same
with Rosie but at least you and Nick one
that's cool that's cool enough that's
cool that was good enough for me I was
like oh that's good I don't care oh my
God all right so quick um on to my next
topic real quick Marty bring up this
because I don't even know what that
means the tickets thing he brought it up
what do you mean people do that so you
got to explain better to me yeah you did
a tweet about one like one of your
friends or some [ __ ] botting tickets to
a concert oh the Taylor Swift what is
that what is that bro the um so it's
like a whole controversy right now with
Ticketmaster so Ticketmaster
um was the one that had a deal with
Taylor Swift to like uh sell all of her
tickets to their shows and then they had
this like Dynamic pricing model or some
[ __ ] but it allowed people to like
resell the tickets at a higher price
instead of like it's always going to be
this price no matter what and um there
was like some problems with like the
servers or something and most people
couldn't get tickets but a little bit of
people could and most people that did
get tickets were like scalpers resellers
Bots or like whatever so my homie bought
like hella tickets for like 5 500 bucks
and they were going for like 500 to take
it 500 a ticket which is honestly insane
already how much she charges yeah yeah
for a one single car one concert damn
and people are buying them for ten
thousand twenty thousand
don't go to a show to go see Taylor
Swift where's the show at wherever
whatever it's whatever City you should
do this on purpose your music's not
pumping as well as it did they needed
something no she's nuts she's just as
big as she always
oh no that's why the demand's so crazy
like people are like Taylor Swift is
famous like that I have no idea I've
never heard a Taylor Swift song I don't
think no way you for sure have you tell
me and then I'll be like oh that's
Taylor Swift then I didn't know that was
her it's in your subconscious you just
don't know when you said it I was trying
to think of her voice I don't know it
I'm not trying to talk [ __ ] about I just
don't know her what's the biggest one uh
I know Kanye West was a dick there
that's all I know about the girl yeah
yeah that was a classic and there was a
Family Guy episode where she was and she
was a dick to Chris other than that
never I don't know anything was that
kind of a Russian like 15 years ago was
it like a long time it was a long time
ago right she that old I mean yeah
that's how long she's been popping for
sure she's like the female Justin Bieber
to me right that's what it seems like
it's like the female Drake I would say
it's like how big that's how big she is
yeah yeah she's like there's only like a
few people that can sell out like the
biggest Arenas in the world and it's
probably like BTS Drake and then like
Taylor Swift's probably up there too
what do you mean BTS it's the Korean
Korean
they go [ __ ] crazy their fans are
nuts but yeah Taylor Swift yeah Taylor
Swift has like the [ __ ] numbers bro
they call this they call them swifties
her fans yeah they're like names sounds
like you're getting swindled
sometimes you'll go through like a
rabbit hole of um because like it's
almost got its whole own like section on
Twitter and they all talk to each other
and retweet each other so you'll like oh
click on one ghost with fans Taylor
Swift fans and they all have like Taylor
Swift is their like profile picture and
their banner and they're like I'm going
to the next Taylor Swift show like that
and they're all like it's a feeling that
it's like Music Company behind closed
doors making it look like she has a fan
not messing her yeah but do it to
certain artists right right
Hearts yeah yeah for sure on certain
ones for sure because I see some
influencer people or even rappers and I
go bro these are fake ass comments
they're always zero zero her fan base is
so crazy that I bet if you clipped what
you said earlier like Taylor Swift has
fans like that it'll like they'll go
after you like they'll be in all your
comments for like videos and there will
be like hundreds and hundreds of them
for like 10 videos straight and they'll
just be like what'd you say about Taylor
Swift like what the [ __ ] that's crazy
that's how [ __ ] crazy
yeah this newest album I think she's
like breaking because she's always been
like that pop Radio Star like almost
like a d not like a Disney star but like
the perfect danger and now she's like
cussing and like talking about her like
[ __ ] so she might do some drugs let's
[ __ ] do it no I'm down I feel
stop hopping and I didn't know that
she's like a Britney Spears big oh [ __ ]
Britney Spears was huge maybe like maybe
on her level and like respect anywhere
close that means she is huge yeah wow
well maybe I'm not gonna listen to this
[ __ ] probably I don't know maybe maybe
I've listened to this one I'm like wow
this [ __ ] is tight I don't know I've
just never was never oh
so Taylor Swift was popping so you want
to take away from this episode yeah I
guess so Jesus Christ so your homies
conned a bunch of [ __ ] people Swift
ends yeah I mean they bought them so
it's kind of like you can't and there's
real tickets yeah
for like insane by using Bots yeah so
what does that mean like he's just like
um it was like a program just like bot
like you know how you get like Supreme
drops or like these drops at least 20
bets oh yeah easy
you probably made six figs damn are you
selling Taylor Swift tickets not that
many for sure yeah I mean you didn't
need that many they're selling for an
insane amount of money people are buying
it's fine every time I see Memes on
pages I don't follow I need to start
paying attention because I saw uh meme
yesterday and it was Taylor Swift but
the music was off and it was you know
when people she's dancing and they do
like the basketball Street
nothing was going on I was like you're
paying 50 bands for this so that's what
that was talking about yeah damn I would
never I don't care who's in concert not
paying for DK for 20. 10K for anything
that's what I'm saying you should look
it up you can see what the highest one
is like going for right now or something
or like what it's sold I know they're
being listed you know what I mean for
that much but I wonder how often they're
being sold for that much Taylor Swift's
concert tickets or something they even
issued an apology Ticketmaster was like
we're so sorry guys we're so sorry for
doing what we did on purpose
laughs
95 bands no way it sold
that's what it's saying
Las Vegas
in Las Vegas
that's crazy that she better give out
some weed at the show or something
yeah we need her to be pro-wee I don't
[ __ ] know wow she's that popping 95k
that's incredible okay so your homie
came up and I'm very happy that's at
least someone made some [ __ ] money
off this lady right it's good stuff and
it's not like it was even illegal you're
just smart yeah
took advantage of that situation yeah
people got what they needed
he was like I know it's frog
guys it's the holidays Santa's watching
last thing you want to be doing is
showing up to the Christmas party with
the overgrown undercarriage manscape
Platinum package 4.0 has got it all for
you to polish up that candy cane and
toast them walnuts up real nice manscape
has got some of their best selling
products and put them all inside of the
Platinum package Christmas is coming up
buy this for your significant other your
boyfriend your husband or your dad but
you know what I'm saying guys it could
be a perfect gift and a little hint a
lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer a weed
whacker ear a nose hair trimmer coming
with that skin safe advanced technology
protecting your balls protecting your
dick both are waterproof both got the
nice light on them you're looking real
impressive and real festive and don't
forget manscape has just recently added
top of the line shower products all the
manscape shower products are sulfate
free vegan and they will leave you not
dried out these are hydrating they're
not going to leave you Ashy Larry chalk
dust board right after good times don't
stop in the shower we got the crop
preserver ball deodorant we got the crop
reviver ball toner once they touch your
set they're never going impact
manscape.com
20 off plus free shipping again twenty
percent off of anything and everything
you buy plus free shipping when you use
our code so that's manscape.com forward
slash Yola twenty percent off plus free
shipping on anything so speaking of last
time you were here crypto wasn't in the
[ __ ] but now it isn't this [ __ ] oh yeah
and last I I don't I still don't get it
but what happened dude some crazy [ __ ]
happened the easiest way to explain it
is if like
Wells Fargo came out and said
hey guys we actually don't have all the
money that we said we did like we can't
make like you can't read we can't
withdraw anymore yeah we don't have any
of the money
and not only is that [ __ ] crazy but
people be like wait like what'd you do
with the money they gambled it and they
lost it all right
yeah they lost nine billion dollars of
customer funds and then it went bankrupt
who did this uh like FTX which is like a
crypto exchange which is like you give
them money and they give you Bitcoin in
return When you say gamble do you mean
like the stock market or you mean like
they just like they just lost it all
probably on like other crypto like money
and like trying to increase their
reserves or some [ __ ] but they're you
know as like an exchange you're supposed
to have like the amount of money
necessary to always have people yeah I
always have people back but they didn't
have that and then it got word like
somehow this leaked and it was like a
competitor that leaked in he was like
Hey I don't trust this little something
um so it was almost like a bank run he
almost like caused a bank run so people
were like what the [ __ ] let me get my
money out and then that's what caused it
to like collab collapse pretty much yeah
and it was the third largest exchange
that was my next question so so it
wasn't like just some small one like
huge people were involved I think Tom
Brady owned
all that money he put in he was doing
those commercials for that place yeah
FTX they had an arena then they don't
have it anymore damn the marina and
Miami
and like the day after they started
there was like pictures on like the
subreddit there's like a cryptocurrency
subred and like the Arena's already
going down it was like the day after it
happened they already taken the letters
off so now does that like unnecessarily
give crypto as a whole just like a bad
look yeah sure for sure I think it
should too like I don't think you should
trust anyone type [ __ ] you know it's
[ __ ] crazy that they're allowed to do
that you know I mean nfts go down too
though yeah it made the whole Space go
down because like in general you know
like a lot of people have a lot less
money now who are the top two companies
uh I think it's Finance there's one and
then it might be like a Chinese exchange
or something second I don't know what
second it's crypto.com or something
people go to buy cryptocurrency they're
going there to do a lot of changes yeah
to exchange their money for crypto I put
crypto on Staples Center Arena yeah just
so they could be like let's boost it
everybody's this is the future
yeah it's crazy stuff that's what they
do with the Miami one yeah so so the
nfts went down I know that because a
couple homies on those board apes and
they're like mobile board hey they've
asked me something I don't want to buy
now of course of all times no yeah but
it goes like it goes super deep because
there's like conspiracy theories and
[ __ ] because it's like
the owner of SPF has like ties to the
government so people are trying to say
he's a plant and like purposely because
he's like not arrested right now for
some reason and he's not fleeing either
but this has happened a couple times
before where people like kind of rug
pull like billions of dollars and they
definitely flee like the all the three
of them went to like Dubai I think
because there's no like extradition or
whatever he's the only one that stayed
for some reason and he's still not
arrested just weird
I don't know all I know is everybody's
kind of sad about it yeah super crazy
it'll go back up that's all he made it's
gonna go back yeah fluctuate like yeah
it'll probably just go back up but it's
like a few I'd say it's like a year or
two hit just because like that's how
long people are like damn like so many
people are just like should know because
that's supposed to be like the safest
place like maybe nfts are risky people
know like certain coins like Shiba coin
or whatever is risky but you're supposed
to like this is the one place you're
supposed to be able to trust your money
and then [ __ ] can't so it's like
uh [ __ ] I think it's still I think the
tech is still there 100 percent but I
think it's gonna be like a big thing
like the whole underlying Tech behind
like yeah yeah I put my money out a few
months ago though behind before that
says a lot yeah he's like I don't trust
it yet yeah I am sure yeah I did it or I
did it because like the economy was
looking bad too a few months ago you
know and everything covet has been
[ __ ] looking bad so how do you cash
that out like how do you turn it into
money you get back uh well you're
supposed to be able to just go to this
same Exchange and be like hey I have 10
Bitcoin give me my money back so they're
supposed to be like hey we have enough
money for 10 Bitcoin here you go we'll
take your big physical place that's
giving you it's like a it's a virtual
assistant
yeah 100 oh just like a all right it's
like a bank account almost yeah like a
website damn yeah I mean that's why I
have to really hurt the Public Image
overall hell yeah it did for sure as it
should too like yeah but yeah not to be
trusted at that point yeah like your
dollar it's not a dollar today yeah
what'd you say but that's what people
are saying is like the government has
wanted to put restrictions on this for
so long and people are saying like this
was like finally the thing they needed
and like why was he the one to do it and
like he's got like ties like his
girlfriend runs the crazier part is like
they had a treasury they had a second
company that was a treasury that like
they took the money for and everything
and he just took all their money
he bought himself and he like played
this image of like being a really Frugal
character and [ __ ] and he's got like a
50 million dollar mansion like the
Bahamas or something
but [ __ ] just like a whole big scam you
know but we'll see what it leads to
probably like some regulation the
government's gonna be like some Wolf of
Wall Street is that crazy just like a
few months like 6 teenage months later
it was the first time you came here
that's sad dude I know so many people
that put everything into it oh yeah
really oh yeah people lost an insane
amount of money because of this like
that's so much
crazy stuff yeah there's even this uh
this Twitter guy that I follow he's like
a crypto Twitter guy and he had an
insane amount of money there's like a
whole other controversy he had an insane
amount of money in the exchange and he
paid someone from the company that was
still left in there because a lot of
them got fired or left so like one of
the few remaining members he paid like
an insane amount of money to to change
his account to like be a certain
resident of like a certain place and
then got all his money out and like
skipped this line and he was like the
only one to do it he got out like
several million and everyone else and
now he's like an international fugitive
type [ __ ] like he's on for doing that
yeah yeah like why is that bad it was
like after the yeah yeah so like that's
the insider trading show right so like
I'm halfway between that like he got his
money like he got [ __ ] like he should
have got his money yeah 100 and then the
other thing is like
I guess if it was like if one person's
[ __ ] everyone should be [ __ ] I guess
is that what some people think that
makes him better than that yeah yeah
that's so much money right you know yeah
yeah I guess that's what people are like
if I got [ __ ] then you should get
[ __ ] too you know
I'm glad you at least you got your money
yeah yeah for sure I got the roulette
table there's times I like my [ __ ]
almost like there's number next to it
but the guy next to me one hell and I'm
like yeah
everybody should be praising him like at
least you got yours yeah
that's something that's not funny yeah
exactly someone got like if there was
the Titanic and only one guy got away
wouldn't you be like yo
tell them what happened man like yo
[ __ ] drown yeah [ __ ] you no you know
that's like ratting on your home he's
like I'm getting in trouble you're
getting in trouble yeah if that was like
the government trying to take it down
though that was a pretty strategic way
they did it that kind of liked
good job
it does make sense
I got some crap addiction
jail
here Mason ready gone
damn all right on the next topic
hold on in that same space though you
went what you bought the original nft
while you were out
no way for the first time
yeah I bought a painting I'm about to go
pick that [ __ ] up after this and Vlog
it they're gonna let me Vlog it damn you
bought it from like a gallery
what so excited it's just this is like
painted by Salvador type [ __ ] yes it's
it's original Prince did you know who
the artist was no I just remember him
posting about it oh okay yeah no what he
does is he does print and there's
paintings the painting is a lot I almost
got it and then I went your Poor's still
bro don't do that [ __ ] don't be doing
stupid [ __ ] you're not [ __ ] 70 at an
auction you know I have to have a top
hat to be buying uh [ __ ] like that but I
was looking at like I said I kind of
want it but I did I got they sell prints
so basically he doesn't print he'll sign
number them and there's only a certain
amount this one's like number 15 of 200
or something wow he did these in 61 I
think but I walked in I saw it
yes in Ferris Bueller when he when he
when he's just spacing out into the
painting that's how I felt like yeah
about to buy this [ __ ] and then I'm
like yo I've never haggled before and I
haggle with him a little I'm like hey so
what if I bought two could you help me
out on the price here oh I've never done
that in my life I go how much that's how
much I'm paying I've never done it even
with wheat
I'm not gonna haggle somebody but I
didn't he goes I'll give you a deal on
one I go oh
he's like here this is
as he was typing the money I go yeah
because I saw another auction with it
for like maybe 52 or 2200 less and he
goes
all right so that's what I can do like
yeah [ __ ] cause John Hash House he is
the best I'm going to see that you come
on man just give it to me 50 off he's
like no I can't do that you know what I
can give you 25.
John you're the master of this because
he's so personable with people but I was
like
it worked oh my God and he went
downstairs and anyway I'm picking it up
after this I'm like yo can I
yeah after this I'm gonna go uh it's
right by uh
it's on radio it's just some [ __ ]
place right yeah and uh
yeah he gave me a deal he's gonna let me
film the whole [ __ ] I'm gonna film it
I'm gonna film what's putting it up at
home
Salvador Dali he's my favorite
artists this is so trippy and dope and
yeah yeah everything since I'm a kid
I've been I've had his Prince from
Spencer's Gifts the member used to buy
posters at Spencer's Hot Topic yeah you
just turn them and pick one I [ __ ]
picked that out I picked like I've had
them every of the course my whole life
so it's just really [ __ ] awesome yeah
I'm excited I've been posting his [ __ ]
since my start of my Instagram oh that's
right that's right random randomly yes
optical illusion style
yeah but if we're gonna create anything
to start buying art
that's what I thought like what's
Priceless yeah I love the watch is great
my art put some art and if I'm not a
huge fan of jewelry like you know go buy
some R I just smoked a donut in my car
the SEC right when I pulled up yeah I
reeked I had vans on and [ __ ] I was just
I looked high the guy looked at me like
yo kid
you don't touch anything okay you just
take your [ __ ] picture and leave
that's how he kind of looked at me yeah
but like yo sir but I was I looked
noticeably [ __ ] up like I would like
to buy this yeah this one like no this
one this one looked up online and I got
like more adult like no I actually
looked at your website and wow he's like
oh you're serious yeah okay but I was
like yo I know I look [ __ ] high [ __ ]
but I do want to throw the duffel at him
like 50 dude
damn it Marty I feel like I didn't take
advantage of the situation
brought a bunch of ones yeah
keep the bag
I made the bag oh man anyway yes the
original nft I love that that was great
yeah that's sick yeah yeah I only know
one person who uh like collects art and
he used to collect a lot of [ __ ] art
and he sold a good portion of it and now
he collects like bongs and like glass
art like from crazy like 50 000 rigs he
was like yeah I traded in like just
listed off some [ __ ] crazy artist and
he's like no I have this and it's like
an insane [ __ ] like piece of work
what would you pick
I don't know
he's a yeah that's tough because he said
because his whole thing was like you can
use one and it like stays the same value
you know what I mean already goes up and
stuff he's like that's the whole reason
he was like I love both but he was like
this one's like because he gets to meet
the artist a lot of the time well or
like go and get out there and like see
it be made and everything so it adds a
little bit more too but if you drop a
painting everybody might mess up the
frame yeah true true sit and cry maybe
that adds to the value though because
it's so fragile
not even something like this this is
like cheap like he'd be like it is
when people when people Rich throughout
it doesn't it's a whole like like we're
talking about oil guys
give me 30. I have [ __ ] five friends
we'll get six each that's how rich
people think I've never it's such a
disgusting mindset like five thousand
dollars is a lot of money it's hard to
get to it like like it's 5 000 like I
always was like man I'm gonna be a
billionaire then I was like damn five
grand is like kind of hard to make yeah
but then you start doing it you're like
oh yeah and then you're like and have
you ever been a really rich guy that
you're like you're [ __ ] dumb you're
rich as [ __ ] oh no no what does he do
that's really that's all he oh no no I'm
a Crusher that's what gave me the motive
the first time I met a really rich ass
dude you're a [ __ ] jackass people do
business with this [ __ ] guy you know
what I mean that piece of motivation
like I just gotta say hello a second
yeah and I just I don't know that was
like the MJ base
that was like the vibe I got there I was
like me oh yeah I survived I got there
for sure but still I just feel it's just
so much money to be buying those rigs
yeah because let's see a hundred
thousand to two hundred thousands like
yo stop it yeah it doesn't even make
sense it's just a one trip away from me
ruining your day I've seen somebody drop
a oh horrible [ __ ] horribly expensive
piece once and it was disgusting damn no
[ __ ] yeah when was this it was the West
Coast Cure it was JP and Jarrett yeah
The Wiz Khalifa foot uh shoe rig the big
like Nike shoe with the see-through yeah
I was at an event and somebody they let
somebody hit it that was someone's
friend of a friend and the friend of a
friend dropped this rig and
I watched it bust what the [ __ ] and the
guy didn't look like oh my bad he was
just like oh I'm sorry
my brother was a 40 000 rig like 20. 35
bands yeah
and your friend would buy 190 of these
that's a beauty
it's cool man it's weird having our own
[ __ ] bong isn't it that's dope
different colors and such yeah it's
these ones hmm so we just changed the
tops
honestly I was just thought it was cool
Eugene tops it's easy to clean why
didn't I think of that why didn't why
wasn't that the first thing I thought of
like it's the easiest thing you can
clean because you just take it off and
just watch the bottom yeah way easier
but um
okay I guess let's get a ballroom [ __ ]
let's go so how do these like because
I've seen a couple people say these are
expensive but for a bong that's like
made in USA this quality that no one
screws and all that [ __ ] like that's
what's 15 crazy like 12 12. that's 1200.
it's comparative
yeah this is like the level of price
wise above like a it's it's a normal
regular it's a normally price book yeah
if you sell these for like 160 175 right
it's a normally price [ __ ] bombs too
right and also it's from another company
so it's not like we're crushing on the
numbers okay guys
um
what I'm saying is like that piece I
would pick that piece if I had to pick a
piece all day because the function in
this even though this is ours I'm gonna
be honest most people like you know you
probably sell if you have a cheaper item
on your Anova site you're probably still
out of it fast as well yeah yeah same
thing with cheap weed people won't even
weed but tell somebody that buys a
hundred dollar ounce every day that it's
130. they're like [ __ ] you but till 1 30
to a guy that buys 600 ounces you're
like no no no what is this [ __ ] yeah
it's all comparative dude because I
think this is a great price bong but if
I was 14 I'd be like how much [ __ ] off
you know how many Zips I could buy
that's it that's all it is great
explanation
So speaking of which yeah we may or may
not be having some
lesson pricing you're trying to beat
around the bush all the time speaking of
that you got your ID deleted and they
got it back yeah how many times has this
been deleted now like 12. I would say
about that yeah 12 15. probably I've
seen you post that at least that many
times yeah
once a month
yeah it's a cleanse yeah it's a nice
cleanse but do you get the page back uh
most of the time I get it back this um
yeah those past two times it would take
like I think it took like three months
and then two months ago so if you've got
really that many times have you ever
permanently lost a page not yet no oh
this is the same account yeah
whoa that is that [ __ ] epic so
they're just like please stop smoking
all this [ __ ] weed on Instagram
you're like all right I will yeah I
guess just keep doing it yeah cause you
don't give a [ __ ]
okay no I've lost 20 accounts yeah and
you don't even smoke weed on Instagram
anymore no [ __ ] I'm done with that I'm
just saying oh yeah you've gotten it
back which is unheard of that's your
original account man
awesome at least somebody's [ __ ]
getting it done and it's great creeping
up on the moon on YouTube right oh we
checked that 20K away or something
you're almost there you're about the
next one yeah I would say like two weeks
out because once it gets there people
like what oh wow yeah close it's almost
there I saw it the other day I saw a
nine something and then I told him this
morning like what's he at right
that hit that number that do weed [ __ ]
yeah it's very cool to see it's a good
point it's like four huh it's like you
four yeah it's like
um it's you customgrow420 and then I
thought you got deleted I think he's
still and he still has a cash account
and he posts Oh I thought he got deleted
like two years ago look at the bump
touching weed yep
no [ __ ] ow wow
um and then who else
that might be it actually that's that's
it yeah
it's two yeah
it's just uh it's cool man it's [ __ ]
awesome that's sick hopefully YouTube
Just changes it could you imagine if we
got paid like YouTubers we got to get
high awesome and we recommended we both
be at 10 mil yeah
instantly it'd be too easy not to the
recommendations man recommendations of
browse feature at home but one home page
on one pen video YouTube would go 10 mil
views I just want a few you know what I
mean just let one go by yeah dude I'm
telling you since I got my [ __ ]
verification or whatever it's starting
to let up nice I got like two percent
browse feature the other day it used to
be 75 80.
two is I for me yes but I saw like all
right they're working it's helping going
up slowly let's go [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
oh man it's so so annoying
do this stupid dance with them
constantly especially because they
didn't for a while like that's the worst
part if it was like from the beginning
it'd be like ah [ __ ] YouTube yeah but
like it was like years for like two
years
yeah as numbers were stacking
I think one time I did a hundred
thousand in one month that's on some
subs three to four in one month that's
it and then I was like how much a month
like on your average 14 went
and 14's high now it's like five
thousand
damn YouTube Slow Down YouTube man I
don't know but you you know and for IG
you get it back you do you getting all
your [ __ ] it's just happening it's with
the territory I think it's just yeah
yeah at least you're getting there it's
[ __ ] sick as hell yeah he's got to
keep going through it you know I feel
like a lot of people give up and [ __ ]
like yeah you kind of have to it some
people like if they're not dedicated for
you stop College because like I'm done
it's not the path right and you left
you've been here for like what almost
two years almost two yeah a year and a
half I'd say like
yeah May of 21. oh yeah so you're coming
up yeah right before his first episode
right I was gonna say February because I
was thinking of no he was here eight
days yeah yeah yeah you came down and I
think you were here eight days before
remember like yo so you lived here for
eight days now yeah I think I was like
the first thing we opened up with in the
show damn that it was a lot of fun times
yeah that other one that was cool has
there been any moments where you like
questioned it or felt like damn this
maybe it wasn't the right choice
she I don't think so not yet I'm always
just like
I don't know I'm really uh I'm really
just like into the space like I [ __ ]
with it like I had a um it was like
another influencer that I was hanging
out with the other day and um he does
like a lot of IG and like Tick Tock like
short form content and he's only been
doing it for a couple years and he asked
me he's like yo like I'm kind of like
just like bored of this [ __ ] or like
what do you do to like keep yourself
entertained and I was like dude I don't
know like I [ __ ] love like weed I
think something like cannabis and weed
is like the next thing like I'm into it
you know what I mean like I love when a
new state opens up I know when like a
first person takes their first rib and
like all that I think that's the whole
point of anybody that sticks around yeah
do you really like it like yeah the
camera's on or off well
um same [ __ ] yeah he's gonna be smoking
moles and your shits you know what I
mean like yeah I want one of these even
if I didn't do it like thank you YouTube
[ __ ] you know that's the whole point I
think that's why the meet and greets are
good for you too yeah so yeah did you
meet anybody from your live chats yeah
I'm in a mod weird huh it's [ __ ]
awesome isn't it weird like what's your
name
no way shut the [ __ ] up oh they say
their real name and then they're like um
why don't you say that from the
beginning you
already like I met some of the people
that are in the chats all the time and
holy [ __ ] is it cool to see people and
put a face to it it's like a pen pal you
never met literally you know what I mean
it's [ __ ] cool I already know that
fool I already know you very well he
knows me and [ __ ] like the coolest thing
is when people will come up and they'll
be like oh it's Kanto and they're like
[ __ ]
dude I [ __ ] love because then again
who did you watch when you were a kid oh
not even YouTube anything like what was
your [ __ ] damn I think it was like it
was Cartoon Network oh okay okay
Foster's home so no no
movies and [ __ ] that you stuck like as a
kid I was like yo I'm the coolest guy on
the earth that was my guy growing up
who's your Adam Sandler was like yeah a
question yeah who's the you know what I
mean like even if it might be music it
might be like it's my favorite artist of
the whole [ __ ] time
there's got to be something
or what do you listen to I don't think
we've ever asked this
uh I listened to a lot of like I say
like hip-hop raps probably number one
and then two is like alternative kind of
like like alternative What alternative
like uh [ __ ]
what's that it's like alternative uh
it's like a band like a band kind of
vibe like almost like punks
maybe okay I thought you meant
alternative like hip hop what is that
okay okay so rap wise like ready
you're if you can have anybody on the
show who's it going to be
okay like if you can if you use like yo
just to talk to him just like just to
have a conversation of something you're
a fan of
um good question yeah you know what I
mean because you have a show now it's
different when you're having people on
your show and you are talking to them is
I'm like great [ __ ] I'm just gonna see
you get asked questions today yeah yeah
that's how I feel too [ __ ] yeah
I was gonna say Kanye but he's kind of
crazy now probably Eminem oh all right
all right okay what was a great answer
what would the question you asked Eminem
what's the first question I don't know
if I even asked them questions I'm just
gonna sit there rant at them about the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
man all right here we go you grew up in
a cold place white right me too man what
else
it was a great answer yeah hell yeah
that'd be awesome Eminem has been around
for so [ __ ] long yeah that's the main
thing because he's been around forever
same thing with Kanye he's been around
forever dude I know Kanye West is saying
crazy things I don't even know
everything he's saying right but I still
know that it's like yo pretend did you
put that to the side damn that music is
hard on yeah that sounds good he's done
some crazy good songs like in terms of
like he's done music [ __ ] clothing
like he's like someone not someone to
look up to in terms of like what he's as
a business brain yeah for sure on Earth
I don't think anybody else is crushing
it in the terms of their variety right
like yo fashion Crush producing Crush
making music Superstar yeah what else
are you gonna do
I'm gonna make a church yeah gospel
music like different forms of music too
is even like a tough thing to do you
know like making one song sounds hard as
[ __ ] I'm making an album it's like
really good then changing up the whole
genre and like revolutionizing like some
[ __ ] like damn some crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] I
mean not only can you do that within his
own music but then he could go sit in
the studio with any artist alive and
produce their sound yeah yeah isn't that
a trip what makes him like a one-of-one
almost yeah pretty much damn near him
like Swizz Beatz kind of like that but
uh yeah like he's it's for everyone out
there we're like talking [ __ ] eat a dick
you don't gotta watch also I'm just I
just like his music talk about anything
else all right
um so okay Kanye West but now he's kind
of crazy I I understand what you're
saying I get that feeling when would
that be like the Optics of Heaven Kanye
and their Booth would be cool here would
you have Kanye in your show right now oh
you can come sit down right there hey
man let's talk about stuff let's laugh
let's give everybody a lot different
show than they would think because on
here like certain people I would like to
think that this is the place where we
disarm and just laugh you don't gotta
talk about the [ __ ] that's going on
publicly or anything like we just had a
guest on that's premiering today uh milk
TV uh Marty brought a show me a selfie
like a reaction YouTube like oh it's
cool it's cool we had him on the show
right cool
next day I gave I gave him a sweater
next day he's wearing our sweater yeah
and he puts up a video talking about
adam22 and like how they're beefing with
each other and all this crazy [ __ ] and
I'm like wait
huh I didn't know that because why I
don't bring a [ __ ] on the show we
could have talked about the the whole
time but I didn't even know to the next
day right like I had no idea and I'm
like wait you're wearing my sweater
talking about this this looks planned
almost man it looks like we're Cahoots
but no the guy milk super nice too yeah
I'm 22. nice as [ __ ] yeah I didn't find
out that they were like really didn't
like each other until two no two days I
went we didn't talk about any drama in
this episode whatsoever because I didn't
know I wonder if we wanted to talk about
it
what do you really need to say kind of
vibe right what do you need to get off
and that's anyway so we have Kanye on
here I be like hey man
that's how we would introduce the Taylor
Swift topic but remember when you're an
[ __ ] to it say hey man come on lift
up his mask come on
foreign
bring it back
Kanye was dope
um oh got these we got these
all right here we go nice here we got
these pretty girls like dude I got one
of those joints cause I only have one
giant one and then one little baby
it's only we that I had left this one I
didn't fit in there because I thought
you know you know what happened
um so you got your page back though so
you're doing good that's great my next
question is
when I went to your show we talked about
it and we're going to update it here you
reviewed Joey Diaz laughing gas yeah all
right how was the weed it was pretty
good I liked it
it's like a Barefoot dancer it's like
eight and a half eight and a half oh oh
[ __ ] okay
great
um I didn't know who was producing all
this ice cream the brand I didn't know
about all this
they used to be called ziki Farms the
people I used to work with yeah I did my
pop-up there nice I've known these dudes
I used to do videos for them and all
that I didn't know that I ran into MJ
bizcon didn't realize they're the same
[ __ ] people so that wasn't
bringing it up because I was supposed to
be on Joey Diaz
show
when I went to uh New York yeah the
second time yeah and then I'm there for
the day and they're like yo he got
booked for a movie and he's leaving oh I
just wanted I wanted to bring up the
laughing gas and tell everybody as an
update because hyped it the [ __ ] up yeah
because we're like yo we're going this
weekend and it didn't go because he left
so I just wanted to let everybody know
that yes Eric has reviewed it it was
fire it's pretty [ __ ] good pretty
[ __ ] good whoa these are crazy
pre-rolls is that how they come yeah huh
instead of long and skinny they're just
short and fat I just got I already
tweaked a little bit but if you need to
do it again also I noticed if you if you
see the little dips here if you pinch it
a little bit it hits harder yeah I don't
know I noticed
interesting yeah it's pretty cool you
guys try this one out I've smoked so
many of these ones you smoke joints in
your free time mainly or is it mainly
just bong or outside uh it's probably
dabs and Bong ribs mainly I'll smoke uh
I'll probably just roll it for the
streams it's really when I roll up these
are like one obsession with the homies
and [ __ ] yeah it gets easier to just
like pass it
um but yeah I don't really face joints
that often every once in a while though
I get a good like uh I will in the
winter time is coming up it's exciting
get like a hot chocolate and Joint
that's awesome you're California man we
don't get that cold here yeah I know but
I'll still take it 50 degree weather now
I thrive [ __ ] Marty
um okay okay we're doing this new thing
of me trying not to ramble so hard you
know so I'm trying to like stand someone
on topic want to hit him with our
recurring segment before the fan
questions
16. okay here we go
recurring segment I asked this on
[ __ ] Tick Tock a long ass time ago
and then we made it a segment
right now
your 16 year old self are you beating
the [ __ ] out of him or is he [ __ ] you
up
you had to fight him I'm beating his ass
for sure yeah
I like to hear that more often than
normal mine's gonna [ __ ] mop the
floor with me no way yeah
I'd like to hear the last time we asked
were like um a 16 year old self would
have did something else to me I was like
oh he would have shot you okay got you I
just like to hear the answer because you
always that's not a question you get
asked very often yeah for sure
Eric walked in like what's up guys in
the game
that'd be [ __ ] hilarious we always
ask um we ask our guests if you could uh
if you had a sword do you think you
could take on a tiger
[ __ ] now what no way I I life or death
I'm killing that tiger with a sword for
sure like in 300. yeah I I don't know I
don't remember the little boy backs in
the canyon oh definitely not easy oh oh
that was a wolf yeah you know what I
mean okay because I was trying to
imagine a tiger I'm like all right no
I'm stabbing that's what I'm thinking
yeah
that's my that's my exact technique I'm
not you're not no no no because once I
miss my next eating yeah okay yeah do
you think you could time it is no I'm
trying to just like I think you're all
over the place with the blades I think
it jokes
yeah and then you're done one clean Kill
Shot exactly all right you better
[ __ ]
reward baby it's all it takes man nice
you're one of the only people to say
yeah everyone's like no hell yeah
everyone says Marty like that Tiger's
[ __ ] me up like if it's like yo
here's the sword million dollars will do
it no if it's like yo you're in the
wilderness you only got a sword or die
it's dead what if you're like in the
Coliseum and there's a crowd watching
that I'm forced to do it then I'm gonna
kill it and start making some
Reflections I distract this stupid thing
oh my God
Marty what I'm gonna do is get into Full
Nelson all right Full Nelson grounded
pound if it lets me sink that [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
how did you feel to get your ass beat by
his overweight kid
wow that's great I love the question and
yes it's dead yeah yep because it's not
a lion you know it's tiny [ __ ] funny
is this was in our fan questions and I
thought it was talking about Tiger Woods
or some [ __ ] oh that's why they asked
yeah oh no no he's a menace he is a
menace he's out there [ __ ] just
he's flipping cars and getting divorced
losing money going bald he's doing crazy
[ __ ] to himself right now letting his
beer grow out he's the goat though he
was [ __ ] yeah that's what I said he's
just literally mean living life yeah if
he was single none of this he should
just be single he should just be single
yeah because you're Tiger Woods bro yeah
I guess so yeah Jesus Christ stop trying
to be [ __ ] not often can you just
exist and walk into a country club and
make all older white men go whoa wow
look who it is you know what I mean like
that's a [ __ ] accomplishment man only
you and Wilt Chamberlain can do that
[ __ ]
Jesus Christ so uh yeah definitely kill
him
I
I
ride in golf carts I swing
I don't think I play golf yeah I think
I'm really terrible I don't think they
can consider me playing golf I'm the
same way but it's fun it's fun to swing
fun to swing
you were good at vlogging it yeah nice
it's a fun Vlog but not a I'm just not
good at it man yeah I mean really if I
crack it I'm like I'll hide it's like
roulette first couple I was like
[ __ ] look at this I'm good at
putting-ish
but I'm not good at swinging that's
about it no I'm not good at golf and
also Tiger's dead 16 year old Eric got
his ass beat
that was the question yeah all right all
right now I'm gonna ask you some stuff
Marty or Marty's gonna ask you a fan
question
two weeks ago we talked about you coming
on the show is it rip it yeah it's
ribbon okay you got to pinch it though
huh yeah yeah without it I feel like I
wasn't getting the air I noticed it in
my bed last night I was smoking one and
I pitched it
um
go ahead bear question take take it away
all right we had a couple people ask us
we're going to go ahead and just name on
Jordan 50 53 here we'll see you the best
advice that you might think about giving
to somebody looking to start a business
from the ground up I am a business from
the ground up you through the internet
that was very vague well I look at
somebody as Eric like Eric and you guys
who have like built up these fan bases
and then built businesses around them
yeah that's the direction is building
the fan base for sure and I'd say
nowadays it's definitely Tick Tock like
there's a certain tick dude I don't [ __ ]
what they talk that much yeah me neither
shame it's a shame because I don't
either and I hate it and I hate short
form content and like The Tick Tock
everything like that but it's just the
way
there's just an insane amount of people
on it is it like all right because it
seems to me like even in business like
people care people look at Instagram
followers they don't in our world at
least they don't call out like Tick Tock
followers and numbers always seem so
huge yeah that's almost that's like the
main thing because it they're real
numbers and they are inflated to a
certain extent but they're real like
people watching it you know what I mean
it's [ __ ] nuts but I would say like a
hundred thousand YouTube views is way
more impactful and like meaningful than
like a million Tick Tock views for sure
but it's just like you can get some
numbers on [ __ ] Tick Tock and you can
start like you can start a business off
one viral video and you know oh yeah
that only takes two three tries you know
what I mean it takes a few ideas but uh
yeah definitely like just go the viral
video route because it's hard to get
your [ __ ] name out there you know if
you're starting a business and whatever
Niche whatever ecosystem or whatever
you're going to go through
there's probably people that are already
running it you know so you got to get
your name out there somewhere how long
did it take till you felt like damn I
got a big ass like legit fan base from
when you started see it was probably
like the first meet and greet you know
like the first time you could see people
because it's always just like numbers on
a screen I feel like even nowadays it's
just like because I asked for a light
goal the other day for the first time
and I don't really do that a what a like
goal like you know like get a certain
amount of likes oh okay yeah yeah and
then I never really did that and I
always remember seeing YouTubers do that
and it was like they would ask for like
20 30 000 likes and I'm like [ __ ] I just
want like 20 000 people to watch my
video like I can't even imagine how many
views it takes to get like 25 000 likes
then I asked for that the other day and
I got like 40 in like two days and I was
like on a video yeah on a video good
[ __ ] and I was like [ __ ] you asked in
the video yeah yes in the video like
like how I used to like see back in the
day and it was like it was almost like a
full circle did YouTube share that with
a lot more people uh not really the view
video before that got more reviews and
but this one got way more engagement so
it's like a more give it to you in a way
yeah yeah are you getting less age
restricted videos
uh damn somewhat it's the it's the cart
videos that don't get age restricted
those are the only ones that don't
because you don't like show anything I
guess or whatever every once in a while
I can get away with a puff code too but
it's really the card you can't get away
with any of the focus [ __ ] yeah you
would think that it's hard to even tell
that's what I'm saying
um it doesn't even make sense so when
you're uploading
you're getting less age-restricted
videos on the cart videos you're not
getting as much
do you buffer zone any of your videos in
the beginning because you know how they
they monitor the first yeah yeah in half
yeah I try to I've always like yeah
because I don't just like start with a
bong rip anymore maybe sometimes you
should do that but then yeah I'll just
[ __ ] oh wait you know try to set up
like some sort of like intro or
something on some like Casey neistat
[ __ ] or like what the video is going to
be about or like you know something
before the smoke comes in and that kind
of helps for sure
that's what we try to do the last story
time we did a 60 second countdown as the
beginning of that yeah is that a bad
idea eat up some time yeah the first
minute like you guys are already rushing
to pack a bowl I just gave you 60
seconds nice and my intro is about 30
seconds we're 90 seconds in some updates
updates I'm just trying to like
I'm trying dude because you know we got
the the YouTube's [ __ ] with us
finally I'm not getting as much age I
mean I am but
it's hard to say it's it's hard I don't
know it's really hard to
to say if I'm if they're still [ __ ]
with me yeah yeah sometimes just like
the people not [ __ ] with this video are
like yeah but I see the comments I'm
like people are here yeah yeah literally
or I always get that too the the shirt
video a restricted still did a hundred
thousand in a day yeah using 100 000 a
day video and so [ __ ] long yeah [ __ ]
oh my god dude it hasn't happened on the
channel forever
but this happened even though it was age
restricted sometimes I'll get that too
yeah an age-related video will go off
and I'll be like that doesn't mean my
last story time did okay and it wasn't
age restricted but the one before that
was [ __ ] all over better it doesn't
even make sense
it's like yo shut up speak yeah
what do you want to do here man that's
how I feel with YouTube man [ __ ] okay so
you don't you don't have an answer
either no don't get it all right
everything just trying to see what works
I guess Tick Tock I gotta get on Tick
Tock I have a couple that did a couple
million views on there so I'm saying
like it's but other than that it's like
what does it do yeah what is is it
monetized at all
um some people do right yeah I think the
biggest ones are the big the big thing
is YouTube's gonna be a YouTube's gonna
start paying you for YouTube shorts I
just started getting paid on YouTube
shorts nice [ __ ] yeah yeah
just see the money comes in it's so low
but
especially if you're getting like a
couple million views on like Tick Tock
and [ __ ] it's just like poached takedown
creators but it's weird it's separated
from your regular like views or your
regular AdSense to begin with super
strange but I mean I guess it kind of
makes sense like they're just trying
YouTube's like a long form platform at
the end of the day and I think that's
what content it's like always gonna be
but I don't know we'll see
my kids sit there and just watch shorts
like yeah all day that is how they watch
YouTube yeah really no I mean I hop off
that page so fast I try to watch shorts
yeah to watch my YouTube [ __ ] but shorts
are cool I don't know oh
right before you got here I got the text
message from my bank
YouTube remember how I got remonetized
whatever it gave me my first [ __ ]
payment ever on YouTube today ever ever
today nice
yeah after we're off this I honestly
believe that you can get remonetized I
just showed Brandon rauji and his [ __ ]
yeah your videos actually get monetized
or is your channel just like damn no way
story time was
one of the weed videos got monetized
and somehow
crop how to roll a cross joint
s really yeah it's going still monetized
damn that's sick they just
what
don't understand it but I think you can
do it I'll show you the button that I
pressed but I think it'll work because
if I come on bro if they can let mine go
on
[Music]
going on I always feel like I was gonna
wake up and just see like
what my bank a sad senses 400 000 that's
what I always hear from like the
YouTuber stories they're like yeah I
just checked one month and I was like
getting six months or like six k 16k
then it was 60k a month and I was like
what the [ __ ] I [ __ ] wish me [ __ ]
sick
but yeah dude I just wanted to know so
you're in the same boat as me still I
thought hopefully it's changed a little
bit
it has to change though because if they
let me on the program there's something
something changed hopefully has to be
some Cog in the wheel is turning a
different way yes oh oh Jordan 50 53
start the fan base oh yeah the thing
usually you can buy off a couple things
yeah also go to as LegalZoom do the LLC
easiest thing you'll ever do pay the
extra yeah the lawyer they'll do
everything for you
invest 700 then go get a trademark from
godaddy.com I mean go get a
website from godaddy.com or namecheap
Go Daddy
name namecheap I used yeah but godaddy's
fine too
um so there there boom but you think
it's easier to start a business when you
have a loyal fan yes yeah for sure you
know but also you didn't start this
videos to be like you know what I need
to make this certain amount of money off
oh right yeah and that's why you're like
I love doing this yeah yeah that's what
separates you from people that you
probably seem not gonna name people that
you've seen yeah you've seen that go
it was six mil to rent that building we
looked it up the convention center 2.1 a
day damn yeah
sorry I just had to say that [ __ ]
that you guys won't be there okay
um
you've seen other creators come and go
because
you can kind of see through it yeah he's
like uh you just started smoking weed
but like you're making videos doing like
why why you know what I'm saying for
sure it's just kind of people are trying
to hop on the culture more than it is
like
just live your life by the way I also
make videos right and then oh [ __ ] they
finally took off
um and then business
like you you should Prince yeah it works
it works dude now you have the Anova
then you transitioned it into legal weed
and other states which is great crazy
legal multi-state [ __ ] week awesome
yeah it's not your childhood Legend yeah
it doesn't even make sense it doesn't
even make sense life is a simulation
sometimes for sure cheat codes are just
being not a dick yeah true yeah true
like because if you're like what's a
secret there's no secret yeah
it's the ability to Parlay from like
level to level and just keep yourself
kind of yeah going with just wherever
you're at that moment because I hate
when you have to be a dick too I feel
like the only time is like Airlines like
the only times they'll [ __ ] help you
out is if you're a dick to him oh no
like if you're nice to Airlines they'll
be like yeah [ __ ] you yeah
they're like all right
I hate being an [ __ ] I know it's
[ __ ] bro last night I told Marty last
night it was my first time ever blowing
up on somebody at the theater nice oh my
God I [ __ ] lost my [ __ ] on this
[ __ ] group of like seven people
[Music]
and then they were doing that that noise
that [ __ ] the internet people like
make those yeah yeah just yelling [ __ ]
and then singing [ __ ] lyrics of songs
out loud before the movie started it was
only three dudes and I'm like you're
like 17 18. it's okay you guys are kids
but after like 10 minutes I looked at
him I went yo
that's all I did I'm like yo I didn't
want to get ma'am I'm like dude what are
you because he's on Facebook he's like
hasn't started
and I went
does it matter though
and he's like it hasn't even started man
I go all right you know what you're
right it hasn't started yet
I just kept staring straight like [ __ ]
this and I turned around there was like
six more people showed up and those are
the adults pulled up with them right and
dude they were quiet and then like 15
minutes in they just started going hard
with FaceTime calls full volume
conversation talking [ __ ] to each other
shut the [ __ ] up fool like yelling at
each other
and then at like 40 minutes in I just
like as I started singing [ __ ] the
new Drake horny ones they were just
singing the [ __ ] lyrics to the song
and I turned around like shut the [ __ ] I
just yell like shut the [ __ ] up yeah I
couldn't take it
I couldn't take it no more and I had the
exchange of me being rude to somebody
but I screamed to this man as he was
trying to rebuttal that it wasn't them
then the last row behind me and then
it's the exit because nobody else behind
me
said it's not us it wasn't even me and
that's not like shut the [ __ ] up and he
looked at me and like
and they all got up and left
I felt like I'm about to catch a ball in
the back of my head I'm gonna catch a
punch in the back of my head because
they all had a little little Gucci bags
it's like
they look real they look real bitter
when they walked off I was like oh I
took my jacket off like
just in case I gotta fight for some of
these [ __ ] fools and dude they never
came back I've never felt more on edge
for 40 minutes of a [ __ ] movie yeah
and I was in the back row so I'm like oh
because there's an exit right next to me
in a row I'm like oh someone's gonna
so I was just doing this trying to watch
Black Adam with the rock with our new
God's son I had a kid with me that's the
only reason why I was like I really lost
it yeah he's like shut up [ __ ] touch
my dick and [ __ ] like yo this is too
much yeah I was like losing my [ __ ] like
he's a little kid right here man you see
him yeah so anyway I got mad that's the
first time I was ever a [ __ ] dick
[ __ ] him but it wasn't really tired when
you get yelled at by a dude in the
theater if you don't die inside and just
shut the [ __ ] up like you're gonna be
that [ __ ] that doesn't realize
there's a kid I felt mean bro I felt
mean I did not like the feeling
anyway cleared out a whole row that
doesn't people don't get up and leave
after like after getting yelled out
they left to one one two they left and
all right [ __ ] they all left and was
like what the [ __ ] is he gonna come back
and shoot my because I saw him like
holding his bag and I was like oh no I
just want you to shut the [ __ ] up man
it's just [ __ ] I don't know
but uh yeah Black Adam bad
really I was shocked I only went because
I got someone to watch all right watch
The Rock be the rock nope it's like with
the effects and [ __ ] like it was graphic
damn motherfucker's arms off and heads
off I was shocked the rock is badass in
this movie dude damn The Rock he's a
superhero huh he's a superhero on this
one but I I kind of watched it because I
just was anticipating to get punched in
the back of the head the whole time I
just I watched some of it yeah I ruined
the movie
so back to what we were saying no I
don't like to be an [ __ ] in public
but sometimes it gets things done like
at the airport or the theater yeah all
right bring that right back around yeah
I remember it [ __ ] okay sorry
Last Cup last the fan questions you want
to go for it all right yeah I mean oh
that's why you said it
what do you think of a tiger one yeah I
didn't know what that meant
spiral speed 12. so you why do you think
you can take on a tiger 1v1 okay now we
know and you're saying yes yeah yeah
yeah I'm saying yes too so you don't
think your soul just shook you got a
live tiger Mike Tyson style getting
ready to charge you dead without it yeah
I got a sword
no I'm dead either way I might as well
try to get out one clean your neck I
think I can get it
yeah you're assuming or I'm not gonna
just jump straight though I think they
will
I think they will yeah what if I just
missed
you're a half inch off because like your
mouth get that neck but what about those
claws that just go hey I'm gonna rip
this head apart real quick oh yeah cause
his claws are coming before that like
the then I'll go through his [ __ ]
hand the sword's long I'm thinking I'm
imagining a Zelda Spirit a story with a
big
yeah that's what I'm imagining yeah yeah
okay
would you rather yeah would you rather
have two little swords or like one big
one one big one
um I'm not gonna that's a great question
yo this topic is crazy but I think
anything bigger than that
done oh yeah you can't take a bear I'm
not taking a hippo I don't know you see
that video that guy fighting the bear
it like went viral a couple weeks ago it
like charges after him if he punched it
yeah shut the [ __ ] up it ran yeah it was
a baby
it was a brown bear I think right is
that they're a little timid right yeah
the smaller ones Still Still A Bear he's
punched it in the face do you remember
the kangaroo I was about to eat that
guy's dog oh yeah and he swapped you can
see how hurt the kangaroo was not like
cried laughing at this it wasn't
physically her but it was like yeah what
the [ __ ] just shots it's probably never
been punched in the face
choking out little [ __ ] animals
because they killed Toddlers and hyenas
his whole life
Jesus what he had the dog in a Chokehold
that was the funniest joke yeah it was
actually like it was scary dude that was
that was scary also Fair nothing nothing
can win I can't find it you can't really
stab a bear all like yeah I can't stab a
bear if you give me a gun depending on
the caliber yeah they might not even eat
like a nine millimeter yeah a nine I'm
dead still but hold on do you think you
could take it out with a full [ __ ]
clip
yeah
I think with enough shots I got it yeah
yeah for sure like as it runs at me I
just dip like dump it into its forehead
yeah because eventually one's gonna make
it through easily it's not like it lets
his brains are off to the side or
something I don't know about bearing
anatomy and [ __ ] oh I don't know I think
so yeah uh bear or gorilla who's winning
that's off this topic
yeah yeah and some King Kong [ __ ] those
guys are vicious okay okay you know what
I'm gonna change my answer because I
always thought bear but now that you're
saying it gorillas bite too they rip
apart they rip apart yeah yeah but I
don't think you remember evil bears are
like Primal yeah I think the pounding is
gonna overtake the the claws eventually
yeah yeah yeah what happened Leonardo
took on one yeah
oh man you gotta watch them
oh yeah he won an Oscar finally right
yeah yeah for that I don't know all
right I'll watch it it's a good one I
haven't seen it that's a great I've seen
Basketball Diaries
oh it really it's like a little older
right two thousands or no no no
yeah oh it's a leader of the camera yeah
yeah yeah it's on her seen it yeah okay
that's classic That's a classic
um actually one of my questions who's
your top three uh top three movies oh no
no movies already talked about actors
because I know you watch [ __ ] movies
you you guys love Batman one of his top
three was Batman too
yeah I got like Tom Hardy
do you see uh you've seen the movie with
him uh
I feel really Bronson
no go watch that Tom Hardy plays a
[ __ ] it's a real story yeah he plays
the world's scariest brother UK's most
deadly prisoner nice you should watch
that that's hard I need to see that one
Bronson
Tom Hart oh he carries the whole movie
he's the only guy
yeah I like the ones where he does that
we're the ones who plays both brothers
that one time that was a good one that
was actually kind of [ __ ] wild
because yeah it was for sure say like
him Matt Damon like Leonardo David oh
[ __ ] you like Bourne identities
I knew it I knew I was like it wasn't
something else like what else is Matt
Damon in he doesn't say Brett Ryan he
got everybody killed yeah
[ __ ] man that honestly dude when I
watched that movie it was I was like 12
11. and it was the saddest intro to any
movie I ever seen there's just people
scream this is full screaming oh blown
open on the beach oh yeah yeah crazy it
[ __ ] me up as a kid
who
solid little actors for sure
all three Oscars oh I don't think that
time always won an Oscar but who cares
damn no way I don't think so I don't
think is that the big one yeah he did
you talked very harder to win it than a
Grammy Grammy is the equivalents
Grammy's for music it's for uh
everything yeah film yeah you see Tom
Hardy entered the Brazilian World Jiu
Jitsu championship and won in his weight
class no way yeah we talked about it on
the show recently that's fires
awesome with the [ __ ] number one
bane just came and [ __ ] everyone yeah
it's always so crazy how like people
have accents like that like Christian
Bale has like a heavy accent
yeah it's crazy yeah American Psycho
yeah American Psycho English dude
crushed it I didn't even realize that
yeah I have the toys completely normal
in Batman oh yeah kinda yeah
or when he's Bruce Bruce Bruce that's
true March no worries
question
all right last fan question oh bubbles
15 64. favorite all-time bong in your
collection and why dang uh probably the
Swiss that I have I just I just wanted
to Swiss for a long time is that like
the Rolls-Royce of glass
um
it's probably up there yeah it's it's
one of those like yeah luxury or sports
cars or whatever it's just because it's
like it was that one point handmade so
maybe not it's not like a hyper car yeah
those would be like handmade ones this
is uh made by like a small team of
people which is probably the equivalent
of like those it's got the little like
the holes in the middle of it right yeah
yeah the Swiss holes yeah yeah it's
function so Nate Dizzle is the one who
originated that design like however many
years ago like 10 20 or whatever and uh
he wanted to make a design
um that created function but still made
it so that the water didn't travel in
many places like this even it's like a
huge chamber for the water to like smoke
up and like the smoke to get stale and
everything oh but then the Swiss holes
are just like they're like the smallest
little tubes that kind of just like go
up you know so it chugs too and then
there's no need for like a separate perk
like this or like there's no need for
like slits or like holes or nothing like
that it just kind of functions um and it
retains flavor retains the smoke it's
dope I didn't realize that's why he did
that yeah it's got some function behind
it it's [ __ ] nuts but uh he retired
from glass blowing for the most part so
for the most swisses are made by a team
but every once in a while he'll hop on
like two or three a year and those go
for like an insane amount of money you
know so that's like a brand or it's like
a style swissberg is a brand
um I'm not sure how trademarked it is
though because there's other companies
that like try to do it and you always
see like the China ones obviously and
like even though they're like I think I
say a roar Swiss so I don't know how
that works but [ __ ]
dude it's the world of glass it's a
function is so crazy dude
I'm not a stoked on I feel you they're
dope my friends are crazy ones yeah not
as though they're like more art you know
yeah they're more to look at they always
function kind of what's the real
difference why is for oil for wax yeah I
get that but like why would the I just
like the bigger just like the bigger
pieces
usually rigs are right right here you
don't want to get big and get stale yeah
like he was saying explain okay I
noticed like
Hash House and Jay like people you would
expect to have the big Crazy Ones there
are like kind of little like always
usually typically like under eight
inches yeah that I've noticed okay
like tibs
oh I love it oh my God storytime orange
Mothership like Jays I almost bought it
and then it was the one that he bought
from the auction that Jay showed me I
saw it it went that much don't think I
care enough maybe I bought it I should
have scooped it because now I saw I went
oh my God because I see him use it was
it like 10. then when a 10 to 12.
I don't care don't care enough that's a
lot of Pokemon for something that might
go hey what's up
is there appreciation with those or not
so much yeah for yeah for certain pieces
yeah not every single bong or every
single something will go up in value but
a lot of them will at least retain a
good amount of them you know what I mean
you know so you can if I I could
probably sell this for the same amount I
bought it for for sure yeah yeah that's
true it's true they hold value at least
yeah they're just so you might not flip
it but you'll be able to put your money
into it use it sell it for if not a
profit because sovereignty is going to
be selling it for more in the future
basically yeah or they don't make too
many of these in this that maybe they
make this like they have certain bongs
that are just this or just that or just
that this one has all three and then
even the other pieces that have all
three maybe they're not this color or
some are full accented so it'll have the
lip so like they're all kind of one it's
like shoes too oh yeah yeah yeah you
know like you might see somebody wearing
pairs you like sick ducks and you see
somebody go by like those are the
[ __ ] blah blah blah blah blah blah
that I don't know glass but I have homes
walking like that all the Swiss this
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] right like
Jay Jay knows all that [ __ ] yeah I don't
of course holy [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
shit's too much for me yeah don't give a
[ __ ] but it's awesome
it is awesome that I didn't even realize
either I heard a story of a piece that
was stolen from a smoke shop and this
guy didn't realize like won what he had
and two that it was one of one so he
tried to sell it oh and then people were
like hmm there's only one of those so
hey wait a minute
[Laughter]
and then right when I'm about to hand
the money just start beating the [ __ ]
I mean what are you gonna what are you
ready if a guy actually comes to sell
you're one of one right you're etching
on the bottom that you did or something
you're not gonna [ __ ] with them a little
yeah yeah that's what I'm saying I'm not
saying come on go beat people up yeah of
course not not advocating people up if
it's like oh you don't got a gun out of
here
lock the door
yeah the spider's caught a fly right oh
damn Marty
what'd you think of me I'm gonna
ponytail what the hell Marty no I'm
talking about the Bronx Tale now you
can't leave
no beat up let's not even say ass
anything yeah
pulpation references are getting heavy
over here I'm sorry Eric nah no worries
my friend here
he's a child
fridge is a child
good awesome when did you start being
like a ghost or like an official because
I know you're always like yeah kind of
like table yeah when we got the table
it's been a couple weeks nice that was a
couple of weeks I was gonna say a few
months
yeah much that's awesome somebody's
gonna know leave it in the comments um
makes for an easier conversation
and I tell you this a lot what do you
think yeah it's [ __ ] whack dude and
now that it's it's just so much better
and then when we're by ourselves
that's impossible the way we were doing
it so do you do some solutions no no we
yeah we're sneaker man every four
basically we do one oh sick yeah like a
recap catch up update reaction style
episode yeah just to catch up because we
have so much [ __ ] going on yeah and
they're my favorite honestly like you're
just talking [ __ ] yeah for the whole
time because you know obviously like a
long YouTube video yes yeah when you
don't have a guest you and Tim probably
just talk yeah going off that's probably
when you laugh the [ __ ] hardest
because you're like yo what else what
are the [ __ ] that I had to say yeah
don't forget to ask them something right
you might be having fun still but it's
more like yo
we're a little more prepared now that
I've kind of morphed into this role in
the sense of like I'm I do a lot of
research and yeah yeah but he's the
ultimate researcher you used to do debt
collection you huddle up and [ __ ] this
is your debt collections so you know
you'll find out everything about you
it's crazy yeah hey what do you do when
you get a call on your phone that you
don't know Google it
right
I did that the other day he's like you
you can Google a [ __ ] phone number
you're gonna be like nothing
never mind
[Laughter]
damn Barney's like I got this calls like
Google are gonna stop stop everything
you just said what the [ __ ] you just say
you can google a number
like Hey Google number yeah shut up what
do you say Google whose number it is
yeah it'll lead you back to their
[ __ ] address and [ __ ] if you really
want it yeah you gotta like
internet's a crazy place what
what yeah I'm a good researcher we'll
just leave it at that
so yeah okay so you also are smart so
you guys are both smart you never know I
just I leave it alone and don't call
back yeah it's not gonna answer it I
haven't answered the [ __ ] phone in
years for a number I didn't know like
yeah oh that's twice I answered yeah
they called right back they call right
back I usually answer yeah and if it's
my area code oh it's probably like an
appointment I forgot to do yeah 100 that
I should apologize oh that's that's
usually today this morning you're gonna
make your chiropractor like oh [ __ ] I'm
not I got so much to do today yeah it's
easy Wednesday stay [ __ ] up
um yo we're doing good we're doing good
right yeah this is great me and Marty
doing a TED talk thing oh that's we're
going to be speaking awesome in like
Hollywood or something like that the one
in Hollywood in January so we're trying
to
excuse me
I'm trying not to rant for 40 minutes
because if you noticed since the last
times we were here they were like three
hours yeah a little structure yeah
they're trying to structure things and
not just go
so
yeah really I was like yo let's keep it
tight [ __ ]
so I tried so that's what we're doing
okay there we go we did it 142. [ __ ]
hour 45 minutes guys we're hanging out
everybody's doing their thing please
give us updates on your company Anova
because we talked about Pine Park we
talked about everything else you're
doing yeah your company does one of the
drops Monday there every Monday at 4 20
every Monday so today yeah what are you
dropping today uh today we are dropping
in some merch actually we're trying to
drop some uh I'm trying to like
incorporate merch merchandise with it I
have this uh this company that looks
looks to be promising they have like
they work with a lot of big YouTubers
and they have some like a great they can
like fulfill like stuffed animal type
[ __ ] like if they have a design they can
like yo we can make like stuffed weed
pillows or some [ __ ] like it's Liz oh
that's weird you say that right before
you got here I got my uh shipment in
finally my samples from no way for that
the logo nice it's a pillow it's a
plushie
oh these are not damn that's awesome so
yeah so you're gonna make a merge yeah
for sure we're trying to like because
that was like a one of the original
things that I wanted to do with it I
wanted people to like wear this stuff
not just use it but like of course
there's a logo and everything as well so
um just trying to get that into order
and everything make sure it's all good
to go if you made designs already yeah I
have a couple designs okay are they
picture designs what is it they're more
like yeah yeah so it's like um the
front's always like the embroidered logo
and then sometimes depending on the
design it'll be like colored and then
the back is where the design is for the
most part got you damn fulfillment and
doing embroidery too yeah yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] I never had no [ __ ] film people
offer anything but like we can like spin
on yours
yeah how can we [ __ ] play you I hate
that we've had a lot of [ __ ]
happening oh surely for surely yeah it
took forever to find so Anova uh you're
dropping glass drops all the time but
once they sell out they're gone yeah but
do you have stuff that's on the site
just yeah
that's what I wanted to do as well so we
have like something called like the
infinite collection which is always
there
um so yeah there's a cool Turtle stuff
yeah I really like that a lot hey thank
you so it's very cool if there's an
infinite amount of time you know so if
you want to cop up some like smaller
things like lighter stuff and mood mats
and [ __ ] that's always there perfect
okay all right so anova.com uh
novasmoke.com
all right so I just wanted to make sure
see there you are baby thank you man
thank you
and every single Friday at three or two
you said uh for the for the Pine Park
podcast it's a noon Pacific time so
that's like three o'clock Eastern oh so
it's 12 here yeah so noon on Friday
every single Friday oh yeah have a show
out Pine Park after dark guys fall that
is that's the name on yeah on all the
platforms and then YouTube as well
YouTube it's not under pine Park it's
Pine Park after it's old platform like
its own I think it's on fun parks page
actually on YouTube and then Pine Park
after dark on all the platforms like
apple got you okay so it's it's still so
if you guys are looking for it on
YouTube Pine Park and then you'll see
all the episodes oh yeah okay just
making sure just all in one place we'll
get people hey they didn't explain it
you can leave a link and it's still
[ __ ] good stuff it's in the
description like when I say you're dumb
sometimes
sorry guys I mean I'm guilty I've done
some stupid [ __ ] on [ __ ] Uber yes
I've done some stupid [ __ ] before Oh
okay got a [ __ ] eye off that stoned I
am I damn
guys did it get up this is a fun episode
I appreciate it guys thank you oh so the
reason damn it the reason we brought up
the TED talks [ __ ] so I don't keep
ranting yeah and then I went and ranted
so that's why this episode's shorter
than normal if anybody's wondering like
why wasn't it three hours again
like damn what was going down here for
12 hours of podcasts I'm not gonna do
that that's a lot of [ __ ]
conversation man yeah you can really
think about it that's great for real
more than most awesome I think friends
get you know what I mean yeah so it's
cool it's cool so guys uh let's hop out
of here let's smoke a couple more bone
rips and then we're gonna do our
premiere for those usual then I'm gonna
pick up that painting motherboard oh I'm
so excited
um thank you where can everybody find
you on Instagram because I know it's
Eric is it just Eric Khan on Instagram
aircon underscore underscore and then
there was an aircon ig's your backup
yeah that one's down though right now
there's always there's one down
underscore is the one to find me aircon
on YouTube there's always like an
updated Link in my most recent video
this okay and for Twitter uh aircon
underscore as well so basically yeah
YouTube and Twitter or Instagram and
Twitter are the same right now
I know I hate when it's not the same
none of it they won't even let me change
the old YouTube they won't even let me
change the name like seeing as you bring
in a certain amount of traffic what do
you think it's not uh you don't qualify
to change your name you can put in an
appeal for 14 days I just said no yeah
that doesn't make sense yeah that's
weird anyway [ __ ] them guys uh let's get
out of here thank you so much for being
here Marty thank you so much thank you
sir Eric appreciate you so much thank
you all for having me guys I appreciate
it every Friday pie Park after dark go
watch a show that you guys can go see
people getting high as hell we already
got a couple episodes with Yola on this
yes you haven't seen it we'll watch the
last latest one what is it called uh
just type it in you'll find it you'll
find it we'll find a park after dark
after dark thank you dude thank you dude
guys this has been dope as usual podcast
have a dope ass day I'm extra high and
Vegas just made my lips crack and dry
yes oh they hurt so bad still dude oh
God
[Music]